that's Chloe and Halle they're a sister
singing duo who also happened to be
Beyonce's protegees et spoke with the
girls at the Radio Disney Music Awards
over the weekend where they gushed about
their mentor and being a part of
lemonade never imagined that this would
happen when we posted that it was like
two three years ago and then we saw it
Beyonce and she signed us from it and
just growing from that and learning it's
just been so great and our EP sugar
symphony just came out yesterday you do
surreal
well the biggest lesson you've gone from
being right well she just taught us to
just continue staying who we are and
trusting in our ideas and what we
believe in and just how poised she is no
great [ __ ] she is it's just wonderful to
look up to that so we love her wonderful
did you guys watch lemonade would you
guys think we had the pleasure of
actually starring in lemonade guys were
in freedom that was so cool just to be
there and be amongst all those beautiful
young women what was that experience
like for you guys it's so much fun we
shot it in December and hanging out with
a man Lunds and daya and IBA it was so
much fun being around all those
beautiful strong women it was a
fantastic experience and we're so happy
that we can even say we were a part of
lemonade's